Okay, let's see.
Well, on the bottom I know this has to be a plus sign.
If this were a minus sign, the denominator could go to 0 when the masses were equal.
Dividing by 0 is something that I don't know how to do.
What about up here? It seems like there must be some situations where if you
set this up just right, nothing happens.
The whole setup is static--aka the acceleration is 0.
The only way we can get a 0 in the numerator is if we put a minus sign here.
Now it's just a matter of saying, well, if m2 is really, really big I expect a positive acceleration.
The system will accelerate in the direction that m2 wants to accelerate.
That happens here.
If m1 is really big, I want a negative acceleration.
I expect the system to accelerate that way.
That happens when the thing we're subtracting --this term--gets really large,
which means this had better be an m1.
Then when m1 is big this term will get big.
If you solved this by doing F = ma on both of these blocks
and got this answer, I'm especially impressed
and I totally encourage you to go to the forums and share your answers with your classmates.